every year something switches in the
brains of these Coastal brown bears
before they hibernate they lose their
ability to feel full and pack on
hundreds of pounds in fact it's become
an annual competition to celebrate these
fat bears this is 747 in summer 2022 and
this is 747 in October 2022 in the span
of a few months 747 and other bears like
him at remote catm National Park are
gaining 20 to 40% of their body weight
and for Bears that's a good
thing
bat bear week is a celebration of
success and resilience in our healthy
population of brown bears it is a
weeklong March style Madness bracket
where the public gets to vote on their
favorite fat bear Kat might has some of
the fattest bears in the world because
of a strong saki salmon population the
salmon R lasts from late June through
September allowing the Bears to Feast
Saga Salon are very nutritious food
actually a pretty high calorie one scky
salmon will contain anywhere between 2
to 5,000 calorie Bears on average they
might catch 10 fish per day if they are
consuming the entire fish they're
getting anywhere between 20,000 and
50,000 calories per day and salmon is a
good source of fat for bears looking to
pack on the pounds they're actually
going to focus on just the fattiest
parts of the fish so the skin the brains
the eggs and females they eat that they
strip the skin they leave it and then
some other Bears or other animals will
pick off those carcasses there is one
particular bear bear 480 Otis who was
observed on the webcams to consume 45
salmon within a 5H hour
period and bears are catching these fish
at Brooks Falls but why are bears
actually fishing it has something to do
with a metabolic process called hyper
phasia hyper phasia is a general term
that basically denotes overeating the
term can be applied to humans with bears
it means that there is a period of the
year right before they go into
hibernation in the fall where they are
eating just as much as they possibly can
in order to try and prepare for
hibernation but bears are mysterious
creatures researchers still don't really
understand why Bears enter this state
there's a few hormones that act as what
we call satiety factors that tell the
body that we're full a couple of the big
ones are a hormone called leptin and
leptin is released by atos tissue and
that is something that helps tell our
body like hey we've got enough stored
energy so you don't need to eat anymore
you're full right now another one is
called gin that's released by the
stomach and it says hey I'm full right
now you should stop eating so it's their
body's not telling them I'm full so
they'll just keep on eating and eating
without that feedback telling them to
stop if they are not moving a lot not
working a lot not using those muscles
then that energy is going to be stored
because they don't need to use it right
then and the way that it's generally
going to be stored for for veres in
adapost tissue so we're getting a lot of
energy that is then being stored as fat
as they prepare to go go into
hibernation so that they can use that
through the winter other animals such as
hummingbirds under hyper phasia before
long migration periods but for most
animals like humans or cats hyperphase
is not a good thing overeating can have
a lot of negative Health impacts you
know heart disease diabetes very well
known all these sorts of things can
happen when you've got uncontrolled
eating and that energy is not being used
Bears then enter a hibernation period
and go into dens at catm what
hibernation really is it's a reduction
in the metabolic rate so the bear is not
necessarily asleep in fact they still
have circadian rhythms where they will
be sort of more active during the day
less active at night so they're still
awake throughout this entire period
heart rate during hibernation I would
think of as being in the 10 to 12 beats
per minute they're just their metabolism
has been slowed down their heart rate
slows down their respiration rate slows
down generally they're not eating or
drinking urinating or defecating though
there are certainly exceptions to that
unlike some other hibernating animals
Bears don't actually see too much of a
drop in body temperature so a lot of the
animals where hibernation was originally
to find are some of the smaller mammals
and they will drop their body
temperature down closer to ambient
temperature and hold very close to
freezing but brown bears will have a
body temperature of around 36 37° C and
then during hibernation they're only
dropping down to maybe 31° C it's about
a 6° drop in body temperature Bears can
also give birth while in hibernation
usually they give birth from late
December up until early February their
metabolic rate will increase not all the
way back up to active state but it will
increase quite a bit and then they give
birth and immediately after giving birth
essentially the the metabolic rate will
drop straight back down to a full
hibernation period and the Cubs will
just kind of climb underneath mom and
they'll start nursing while Mom
continues to
hibernate and all that fat that's been
stored up helps them to survive a Long
Winter Bears store all this fat going in
hibernation so that they have energy so
that they can survive through the winter
they'll lose between 25 and 40% of their
body weight over the winter that's going
to be higher for like females to give
birth they're going to be closer to the
40% range some of the really large males
tend to be closer to the 25% range one
interesting thing that fat is not only
giving them energy it's also providing
so the catabolism of fat also provides
water so we mentioned that they're not
drinking all winter long this is one way
that their body is able to get a little
bit of water since they're losing water
constantly through respiration and stuff
like that they do need to offset that
somehow and the catabolism of fat
actually creates water that they're
using as well doing of this type of work
on Bears can be very challenging
hibernation is fairly well studied
physiological State despite that we
still don't really know what triggers
hibernation it's really tough to nail
down precisely individual factors
particularly when a lot of times it's
not one factor that's triggering it it's
multiple things that are working in
concert that might lead to Bears
changing physiological States like this
so who will win this year's fat bear
competition one of those big contenders
is the reigning Champion 74 seven he
still looks really really good when he
came out of hibernation I was fortunate
enough to see him the first week of June
and I was like oh my goodness this is a
bear that lost onethird of his body
weight there's some other large males
that are also looking really good number
32 chunk there are also some females
that are in the running for it bear 128
creaser she is looking really really
good